welcome back start with me joshing haste
and today we are joined by the ultimate
galpão leather
[Music]
it's film the main Disney villain in it
is Rao's insecurity right and I feel
like you could get the ultimate gal-pal
pep talk
the ultimate gal-pal pep taught me for
those down moments what would you say to
someone just breathe first of all take
everything in proportion
count your blessings enjoy the here and
now don't worry too much about tomorrow
the best within the past I find that so
many of the cliches are just so true
yeah so I have a bunch of those going
and this is your first voiceover role
which I find unbelievable because you
have the most seductive voice in the
planet in my opinion what are your top
tips for nailing a seductive voiceover
it was first experience for me yeah so I
was just mainly trying to be me and be
comfortable in the room because it's a
totally different experience than
anything that I've ever done before
and I must say that working with Phil
and rich on this movie was great and
they made everything so they made this
experience they just so great you were
also the ultimate boss you are vice
you're an absolute boss you are what's
your top tips are being a boss
I think surround yourself with an
inspiring women follow your dreams
never let anyone take you down yeah
believe in yourself yeah and just just
go for it and do it
[Music]